حزب
علما الوحده الوطنيه يعلن تبني المبادئ
العالميه للديمقراطيه الاجتماعيه وارساء
قيم الجمهوريه والمدنيه والحريه يعد من
ابرز الاحزاب السياسيه بعد اعلان
الجمهوريه وقائد جبهه المغارضه طوال سنوات
حكم العداله والتنميه حزب الشعب الجمهوري
[تصفيق]
خلال حرب الاستقلال كشف مصطفى كمال
اتاتورك في السادس من ديسمبر كانون الاول
عام 1922 عن رغبته في تاسيس حزب سياسي
تتوافق اهدافه وفقا لرايه انذاك مع تحول
مسار الحكم في البلاد وبعد اقل من عام
واحد فقط وتحديدا في التاسع من سبتمبر
ايلول عام
1923 اعلن اتت تاسيس الحزب تحت اسم فرقه
الشعب ولاحقا تغير الى اسم فرقه الشعب
الجمهوري ثم استقر بعد ذلك على اسمه
الحالي حزب الشعب الجمهوري في عام 35
حمل الحزب شعارا بخلفيه حمراء مع سته
اقواس بيضاء ترمز الى المبادئ المتمثله
بالجمهوريه والعلمانيه والشعبيه والقوميه
والدوله والثوره ولكن على الرغم من القيم
التي اعلنت تبنيها بقي الحزب مهيمنا على
الساحه السياسيه حتى ظهور التعدديه الامر
الذي اثار انتقادات كبيره ولا سيما في
الاوساط الاعلاميه
لم يمر سوى عام واحد حتى فتح المجال امام
تعدديه الاحزاب وفي اول انتخابات عامه
اجريت خسر الشعب الجمهوري امام الحزب
الديمقراطي بزعامه عدنان مندريس فانتقل
الحزب بذلك الى جبهه المعارضه حتى عام
1960 وحقق في انتخابات عام 61 المركز
الاول لكنه اضطر الى التحالف مع حزب
العداله خليفه الحزب الديمقراطي فتاسست
بذلك اول حكومه ائتلافيه في تاريخ تركيا
واستمرت نحو سبعه اشهر فقط
يبدي الحزب ميلا واضحا الى القيم والمبادئ
التي يتبناها الغرب ويقف على مسافه مع كل
ما يرمز الى الدين او المفهوم الاسلامي
فدع منذ تاسيسه وما يزال الى عدم خلط
الدين بالسياسه وعارض انشاء مدارس الائمه
والخطباء التي تعنى بتدريس العلوم الدينيه
فهو يؤمن ان خريجي هذه المدارس لا يصلحون
لدخول معترك السياسه ولا لتولي مناصب
قياديه في البلاد الرؤيه نفسها تنطبق على
قضيه الحجاب اذ يرى الحزب ان الحجاب يقيد
المراه ويبقيها اسيره النظام الابوي وكذلك
الامر فيما يخص النظره النمطيه الى اللغه
العربيه وهو ما دفعهم شاهدين الى احياء
الابجديه اللاتينيه
عشان
لم يشارك حزب الشعب الجمهوري خلال
تسعينيات القرن الماضي في اي من الحكومات
الائتلافيه التي نسبت اليها الازمات
الاقتصاديه الكبيره التي شهدتها تركيا
انذاك حتى وصل الامر بالناس الى حد
الاستياء من الوضع المعيشي العام فداقوا
درعا بكل الاحزاب السياسيه التركيه وهو ما
جعلهم يختارون حزب العداله والتنميه بديلا
في عام 2002 في وقت وجد فيه انصار حزب
الشعب الجمهوري ان حزبهم ناء بنفسه عن
الازمات تلك لكونه لم يشارك في الحكم في
اي من الحكومات حينها
لم يصل حزب الشعب الجمهوري الى سده الحكم
الا من خلال تحالفات سياسيه وكثيرا ما مثل
جبهه المعارضه بعد ان نني بهزائم لسنوات
طويله الى ان تولى كمال كيليشتا روجلو
زعمت الحزب عام 2010 خلفا لسلفه دينيز
بايكال الذي استقال في العاشر من مايو
ايار 2010 على اثر تسريب شريط فيديو سري
له ينطوي على فضيحه اخلاقيه عزا الهزائم
المتكرره للحزب الى فقدانه اصوات الناخبين
المحافظين وهو ما دفعه الى تبني مسار
خطابي جديد حاول من خلاله مغازله الفئه
المحافظه من الشعب فرشح في عام 2014 اكمل
الدين احسان اوغلو الامين العام السابقه
لمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي من اجل منافسه
اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه وفي يونيو
حزيران 2018 ابدى رغبته في ترشيح عبد الله
جول لكن بعض حسابات السياسيه اسفرت عن
ترشيح محرم جاء الذي حرص على اظهار نفسه
بمظهر ملتزم دينيا من خلال تاديه صلاه
الجمعه في المساجد واكد مرارا ان لا مشكله
لديه مع الحجاب والمحجبات في عام 2019
حافظ الحزب على انتاج السياسه نفسها وراعى
ان يكون مرشحه في بعض الولايات وخاصه في
اسطنبول منتميا الى اسره محافظه فاتفق على
ترشيح اكرم امام اوغلو للمنافسه في
الانتخابات المحليه بعد ان روج ان مرشحه
كان يحفظ القران في صغره ونشر صورا وهو في
احد مراكز تحفيظ القران للتدليل على ذلك
البعض راى في محاولات الحزب للاستفاده من
شخصيات تتصف بالتدين خطوه لا تنطلي على
الشعب ولا سيما انه حاول ذلك من قبل حين
جلب شمس الدين جونال تالي المحافظ الى
منصب رئاسه الوزراء خلفا لحسن ساكا الذي
قدم استقالته لكن تلك الخطوه لم تغير من
نظره الشعب الى الحزب فخسر في الانتخابات
التي اجريت عام 1950
ترفح زعيمه حزب الشعب الجمهوري في شباط
فبراير عام 2022 شكل الحزب تحالفا مع
احزاب سياسيه معارضه عرف باسم تحالف طويله
السداسيه واتفق على ترشيح كيليتش زعيم
لحزب الشعب الجمهوري لخوض سباق الانتخابات
الرئاسيه يتعهد
على الغاء النظام الرئاسي والعوده الى
النظام البرلماني ويعارض سياسه الباب
المفتوح التي انتهجتها الحكومه حيال
اللاجئين فاعد في اغسطس اب 2022
250 الف منشور توعد فيها السوريين
باعادتهم الى بلادهم في غضون عامين اما
اقتصاديا فيعد بتحسين الوضع العام في
البلاد من خلال جلب 100 مليار دولار من
الاستثمارات المباشره فور الفوز بالسلطه
ويتعهد بتحسين مستوى معيشه الشباب وتقديم
منح دراسيه لهم وتسهيل دفع قروضهم دون
فوائد
وزياده رواتب المتقاعدين ومنحهم مكافات
ماليه وعلى الصعيد السياسه الخارجيه يعد
الحزب بعقد مصالحه مع سوريا وبتحسين
العلاقات مع الكثير من دول الغرب وبالعوده
الى مفاوضات الانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي في رايك هل ينجح الحزب بتحالفه
في ازاحه العداله والتنميه عن السلطه بعد
عقدين ونيس من الحكم